Hmm.
The last lesson introduced you to clauses and gave you a brief definition of a
sentence.
This time we move on to phrases.
Phrases are basic units and sentence structure.
They allow us to group words together and do broader units where each group of
words acts as its own unit.
Every phrase has a head word,
which is the main content word or the main function word in that phrase.
So when noun phrases based around now and the now and as the head of our phrases
based around a head verb and a prepositional phrase around a preposition,
phrases have three parts.
The first part is the head,
the main word mentioned above.
The second part is to compliment,
which may be optional and usually occurs next to the head.
It's adjacent to the head.
Hmm.
The third part is the specifier,
which qualifies the head in some way.
Let me give you an example.
In the red car,
the word car is clearly the noun in the noun phrase,
so it's the head word of that Noun.
Phrase red,
which occurs right next to the noun,
modifies the noun.
It's an adjective and the word the specifies to know
a key feature of phrases is that they can embed into other phrases.
You'll notice that phrases will build up into other phrases which will then
build up into larger and larger phrases until we get to a sentence which is
itself an entire phrase.
So all of these are grammatically connected units.
Here's an English example of a phrase and betted into another phrase.
Prepositional phrases have a head word,
a preposition like two,
four under before prepositions are used with nouns and the nouns going to be
part of a noun phrase in the propositional phrase to the store.
I have a preposition to and I have a noun phrase the store.
I don't look at them.
Side by side is parallel words.
Instead I see that the noun phrase,
the store in beds into the preposition or phrase to this store,
and this is a key feature for building sentences with phrases.
When we use phrases to look at the structure of grammar,
this is how language is built.
Sentences,
how do we display this embedding hierarchical structure visually?
Well.
One way to do it is with brackets.
This is straightforward enough with simple examples like the preposition or
phrase to the store.
We'll put each phrase into a set of brackets so we can enclose the entire noun
phrase the store in brackets.
After that we put the entire propositional phrase to the store and its own set
of brackets and that allows us to write out the structure of phrases so that we
can analyze them and discuss this embedding syntex behind them.
We focused entirely on phrases,
but there's a competing model of basic sentence.
Instead of looking for unit chunks of language phrases,
we can consider how words depend on each other instead of a simple phrase.
Analysis of my boss ate soup begins by breaking the sentence into a subject noun
phrase,
my boss and a predicate verb phrase ate soup where the predicate breaks down
further into head verb and the verbs object in a dependency analysis.
On the other hand,
the verb has a subject and an object that depend on it.
No main verb,
no subject of a main verb and no object either.
This keeps the discussion at the level of the words and the relationship to one
another rather than abstracting up to larger and larger phrase units.
Crucially though it does not break sentences into subject,
the doer of the action versus predicate,
the action and everything acted upon.
Take the other example to the store.
The preposition to as a dependency that goes this way,
and the article depends on the noun governed by that preposition phrases or
dependencies are two ways of breaking syntax down into the smallest relationship
between words.
Once you understand them,
it's time to move on to the next lesson.